photo véronique bonne année comme
flaubert
ça faisait maintenant comment ça va
moyen puisque je suis encore là mais un
monde de dingues dans la salle d'attenté
toujours après les fêtes ça vous dérange
que j'attende là oui ça m'est rouge
commence
j'y mettrai ça y est j'ai un truc hyper
grave sortie si j'ai une salle d'attenté
est en effet une urgence parce que ma
secrétaire wendel je te dis de ceinture
tout de suite mon cabinet pardonnez moi
vous lisiez un gros sentiment de stress
et ça là excusez moi vous devriez pas
touché servi des années 90 est infestée
de microbes et de maladies de peau a
pensé à tous ces malades quand on est
des pages en sang comme ça oui mais les
salles d'attentes c'est une invention de
médecins pour multiplier la clientèle
c'est pas nous qui attendons le docteur
c'est le docteur cas tant que toutes les
maladies se propagent lui entre tous ces
patients